hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i'm playing a
game you've probably never heard of
called immortals phoenix
rising it used to be called gods and
monsters which you may have heard of
just got to rename and i do have to say
ad read voice
this video is sponsored by ubisoft and
immortals phoenix rising is a game about
customizing your hero
and discovering a variety of puzzles
vaults
and mysteries yes
basically i got to play about two and a
half hours of a work in progress build
of the game got to mess around in the
open world to do a bunch of exploring so
this is that just gliding on into the
open world here having a good time hope
you don't take fall damage
oh cool no you super dude that's great
heading into my first fight
i'll sneak up behind this dude neat
whoa where did you come from
jabba the hot ass looking ass
one ass medusa headass
punk i ran out of insults real quick on
this dude
uh i believe that's what the kids today
call a yeet
oh my god are you kidding me
i think i'm out of stamina i am i can't
use my cool abilities
that's a devastating blow
but uh oh i can use my phoenix yeah
get wrecked by bud yeah
dude look at me being a
god very small
puny god as hulk would say but a god
nonetheless
there's our second year of the day uh if
you couldn't already tell
basically if you guys didn't know the
game is about fighting big old
mythological beasts
uh and you have your own god-like powers
it includes
flight combat i believe i haven't tried
that yet obviously um
as you like explore stuff from greek
mythology do you
hang out with greek gods like aphrodite
and athena
and it's actually narrated by zeus and
prometheus which is
pretty cute a puzzle huh
um some kind of weight situation
it's a shame i'm an idiot okay
i got the heavy one
if i get off it won't work ah
light block okay that's gonna be it it's
good
it says on the screen oh my god alana
okay we got it we figured it out
everyone just ignored what happened
earlier um editor could you please cut
that can you please
another puzzle huh time to put some more
disrespect on my family name
all right well that didn't go great but
we got through it
summon horse
yeah ooh
ooh yeah you can craft potions by the
way um that's what the blue mushrooms do
interesting my nemesis
a log no match for me
and then maybe i jam the other door with
it to get through
maybe oh brilliant not what i expected
okay time to get chest
that's what he said ah a new mask
yeah wait am i not wearing one right now
oh it was just invisible it's 40 damage
six seconds when stunning an enemy what
are they very cool
stone glare what do you look like
oh my gosh i want to see my whole kit
yeah dude i am definitely really
enjoying the exploration especially the
the breath of the wild style climbing is
super cool oh
oh this guy's a lot meaner than i
expected um we're only getting to see
one region in this demo but i believe
that there are seven total each inspired
by different gods which
sounds really cool and it is actually
open wild so excited to see that
oh my gosh oh okay he got the birds he
got the birds it's fine we're not gonna
die we're not gonna die
stupid hoppies okay arrow maybe
get out of here oh my gosh that got so
spicy
get rid of this big cut
okay okay
got it there's another thank you for
that i didn't realize that
you need to collide
i am a god
hurry up with my damn croissant
what are these good parry though alana
these little like tin men are they
robots
oh that was a whip is this like maybe
like a mini boss fight
damn all right okay you have nice a lot
of nice
just me and my boss we go for a walk
it is nice and light
the other one's going to be heavy god
damn it i need to gain some weight
okay got it brilliant we did it
oh my god i'm so smart i'm so smart see
if i climb this real quick
to give you guys an example it
absolutely works like breath of the wild
okay okay
okay he's much bigger than the other
boys
all right okay
what do you got oh fiery projectiles
that's cool nope
immediately how you like them apples
though
like it when you do the weird floor
thing and i'm out of stamina and
running out of health potions and this
is much
more difficult than i expected and then
like you also shoot lasers from your
hands
oh but they don't go past the stairs um
we've discovered a flaw in your design
take hammer we just noticed the running
animation
oh i've really worn you out love oh my
gosh
oh no oh
oh it happened
oh man
thank the gods that are featured in this
game i suppose
his workshop came forward all right we
did it
so i guess i have to unlock them all
oh okay cool oh
brilliant nice work elana good job oh my
god thank god it went away i don't have
to do that again
i hate myself
[Music]
okay maybe i have to hurt myself on this
one
it's fine got potions
um okay puzzle ready to go
all right this is where you gotta stick
your fist in there real yeah real deep
sometimes you really gotta
really gotta dig in to the ring quiet
coins of
charon that was actually a really cool
puzzle
a multi-layered puzzle got some portal
vibes relationships complicated
i mean you and me these guys are just so
dry
am i right all right so this guy
specifically is definitely a boss
lieutenant brontes that's not a bad
sneaking up on him
it's mean you know really
inconveniencing his little feats
i'm sorry bud oop sometimes it do be
like that all right
oh man the uh dude you did so much
damage
um the stamina management in this game
is actually
like super important uh thankfully you
don't get that slow
when you're stabbing as long but losing
the ability to
do your cool hammers and stuff is a
significant disadvantage
um and i don't have enough mana potions
on hand all the time
like a one right now um obviously the
bird attack
uh if you use your phoenix it makes him
drop blue which will give you stamina
but uh yeah it definitely requires a lot
of thought
i i appreciate it in a fight like this
for sure
well you can parry those i feel like i'm
actually paying a lot more attention to
the combat in this fight
because obviously the parries and the
dodgers
managed to get away from that dodgers
will slow down
um get my
mana orbs back please
more hammer time it's the only thing
that does a lot of damage to them
that cleans my stamina all right bud
you're so close to dying
nice clean dodgers in here this is
feeling real good
this feels like it'll be a good place to
in the video too
yeah take that brontes
oh it is what are they called uh
lua a giant musical instrument
this is super cool it's probably also
gonna be some kind of puzzle
that's memorize the melodies with small
wires and play them on the big lie i
found in the same region complete the
myth challenge
throughout the world bam okay i'll find
little tiny instruments and bring them
here is there one more
back here nope okay not what i wanted
one more nope not what i wanted okay
let's try that again
great go to the right no not on his knee
not what i
no no okay well didn't even hit that one
at all
okay here we go feeling good about it
feeling good about it
oh you kidding me
should just start again at this point
shouldn't i it's not it's not gonna
classic
oh my god thank you okay
tell me your secrets tiny liar
what do you that's gonna be one three
two
three sweet uh
get a chest before i go on
all right one three
i think it was two three two
three right
damn this looks pretty
another ring to enter yeah let me fist
you
give me your secrets gotta line it up
pow um all right thank you guys so much
for watching and thank you to ubisoft
for sponsoring this video
there will be a link in the description
to where you can pre-order the game if
you are interested
um i'm alana i will see you guys next
time bye